Freunde wir sind heute auf der Anuga der
weltgrößten Lebensmittelmesse um alle
neuen foodtrends zu entdecken und für
euch zu probieren wir haben Cannabis
Chips käseekracker ein 100% pflanzliches
Steak vegan Thunfisch verrückte
Hafermilch und einen alten Freund
getroffen legen wir direkt los erstmal
den Tag starten mit ein paar Cannabis
Chips welcome to Anuga contain any no no
dann ist ja langweilig does it contain
any
CBD
Cannabis Aroma
bisschen scharf aber man schmeckt kein
Cannabis aber lecker lecker aber die
haben n
mitabis gucken wir mal rein wir dürf
Auspacken bin
[Musik]
gespannt ja ich weiß nicht wie dies
Video gerade
angefangen
ja also zum Glück hat es weder nach Gras
noch nach dick geschmeckt und es war
auch nichts drin ich sehe das 100% so in
Amsterdam oder so in so den Rotlicht
tuour Vierteln wo für 10 € eineen für 10
€ so eine Tüte dick Chips kaufen hello
my friend das ist 100% Käse nichts
anderes nichts anderes 100% K aber so
bei so diesen was man in Amerika kennt
diese cheese Puffs und so da ist ganz
viel anderes noch drin oder da ist wenn
du guckst also wenn wir jetzt nach
hinten schauen dann steht da nur Käse
nur Käse 100% halbgeifter Käse ja dann
probieren wir mal oder biteschön
biteschön Käsesnack 100% Käse nicht
gefrier getrocknet irgendwie anders
gucken wir mal ob das was kann erinnert
mich sehr positiv an eine Sache und zwar
wenn man so eine käsebrzel hat oder so
diese kleinen käsesnacks aus so Snack
miix und da ist oben drauf ja auch
dieser angebackene Käse und so schmeckt
das mein Favorite ist Gauda auf jeden
Fall oh
ja in Deutschland no joke für Leute die
Käsebrötchen den Käse
das per das der perfekte ihr müsst keine
Käsebrötchen mehr für den Käse
kauen wirkich sehr lecker und 100% Käse
ohne Zusatzstoffe sehr gut gute Arbeit
mein lieber danke schön dan noch Ciao
ich würde diesen Käsesnack unironisch
ein neuen von Zeh geben wenn man diesen
Käsebrötchen Geschmack liebt weil genau
das ist es nicht mehr und nicht weniger
der Gerät ist da der Gerät döner macht
schöner Jungs aber nur Döner ne ich weiß
ja noch wir hatten ja echt Probleme mit
dem Döner schneiden ne jo das stimmt als
wir den Dönerspieß selbst gemacht haben
mit dieser günstigen Maschine ging gar
nicht mit der Gerät ist das anders aber
s ist das nicht der Gerät mit
dönerrobot schönen Tag euch noch ne c c
mein erster Döner geschnitten von
derget mein letzter Döner geschnitten
von derget aus Griechenland eine
feterkäsealternative die vegan ist mit
schwarzem Trüffel ich bin gespannt wie
gut Veganer feterkäse ist weißt du noch
letztes Jahr wir hatten diesen veganen
Mozzarella vor zwe Jahren der da nicht
so rank kam seitdem ist viel passiert
die Textur ist immer noch nicht 100% da
aber diese käsenote und das Mundgefühl
nicht schlecht auch diese Säure die
feter mitbringt haben die auch gut
getren ne ja in dem Salat geht das total
unter glaube ich ich probier noch einmal
smoke naturally danke schön und sehr
sehr gut hallo ich gehört dir soll gut
sein pumpkin Spice Barista hafermch yes
ohow okay probier pumpkin Spice es
riecht richtig süß schön nach Kürbis
sehr
lecker
SuG so Freunde jetzt noch einen Kaffee
abgestaub mit dieser pumpkin Spice
Hafermilch schöne latteart schön
geschäumt wir probieren mal mit Kaffee
perfekt passen zu deiner wunderschönen
Jacke danke schön mein lieber ohne Witz
ich finde das richtig gut ich trink
sonst gerne K beim Kaffee Hafermilch mag
ich auch aber diese schäumt gut schmeckt
gut und hat vor allem so ein special
taste und special touch das so instant
instant pumpkin Spice latze so mäßig und
es ist einem voran absoluter
herbstgeschmack also sehr geil und wenn
ich jetzt begeistert von irgendwas
spreche nur um es mal gesagt zu haben
das ist kein Werbevideo ich bin weder
von der Anuga bezahlt noch von
irgendeinem stand bezahlt ich zeig
einfach nur die Sachen die ich hier sehe
und hier sind viele Sachen und viele
sind scheiße ich zeig die Sachen die ich
cool finde damit ihr bescheid wisst viel
viel vegane Ernährung Ersatzprodukte was
ja auch super ist ich meine manche
Sachen die wir hier gesehen haben z.B
dieses vegane Steak es sieht so real aus
und ich muss das ausprobieren weil wenn
das so schmeckt wie es aussieht dann
gibt's keinen Grund mehr normale Steak
zu essen also sehr interessant sehr
geile Produkte hier gefühlt auch noch
spannender als vor zwei Jahren als wir
schon mal da waren gehen wir zum Steak
hier soll es es jetzt tatsächlich geben
das vegan ist fake und das sieht
wirklich zu krass aus hier ist ein dry
Ager mit so die bieten also beides an ja
hier gibt's sowohl Fleisch als auch
vegan guck mal hier so ein Dry Aged
recod ne ich glaube das dauert noch ein
paar Jährchen bis bis das geschmacklich
abgebildet werden kann aber gespannt bin
ich alle Male schau mal her das ist
unser veganes steck aus weißen Protein
vom optischen her schaut's aus wie ein
Steak und jetzt schneiden wir das ganze
auf und probieren mal gerne gerne gerne
und das sieht halt V real komplett aus
im rotzustand wie ein onreod ne also
schon sehr spannend von der Präsentation
her auf jeden Fall das beste pflanzliche
Steak das ich hier gesehen habe und
jetzt bin ich gespannt wie es
schmeckt es hat schon noch gewisse
Textur und Geschmack Unterschiede es
schmeckt sehr gut und ich glaube gerade
wenn du dich vegan ernährst und
vielleicht 4 f Jahre gar kein Fleisch
gegessen hast und mal wieder Lust darauf
hast die Erinnerung nicht ganz so
präsent hast dann könnte das schon
richtig echt rüberkmen aber für mich
persönlich ich esse ja Fleisch merkt man
auf jeden Fall ein krassen Unterschied
ihr hab aber auch richtige Steaks hier
ne wir haben auch richtige echte Steaks
hier genau dann schmeiß mal eins liefer
oh das klingt doch schön er ist am
Strahl das ist ein absoluter
Traum also Freunde visuell sehr sehr
stark geschmacklich geht da noch mehr
ich hätte mich gefreut wenn ich in
diesem Jahr hier so ein labgown Steak
hätte testen können also quasi ein Steak
das im Labor gezüchtet wird aus den
gleichen Fasern wie ein echtes Steak
weil dann wäre es wahrscheinlich
geschmacklich auch identisch bis dahin
ist das eine coole alternativepp hat
gesagt 1 kilog von diesem labgown kostet
mit also kostet noch 13000 bis 20000 €
verständlich warum ich noch nicht
probieren kann aber auf jeden Fall
interessantes Thema zu beobachten und
für alle die vegan sind ist das glaube
ich eine super Sache okay hier sind wir
also angekommen beim veganen tunfishch
und das sieht wirklich krass aus so in
dieser Dose auch diese fasigkeit in drin
ihr merkt auf jeden Fall viele vegane
Produkte heute dabei aber ich glaube
dass die meat Trends auf der Anuga das
wurde auch so geschrieben einmal
snacking sind also so kleine Happen die
man immer gut essen kann und natürlich
auch vegane Ernährung das jetzt auch
schon seit Jahren das ist einfach ein
Ding darum zu und da sind schon tun
Sandwiches hier direkt vor meiner Nase
kann aber auch pur probieren und das
würde ich auch glaube ich zuerst
machen Co seid aus Deutschland wir sind
aus Deutchland kommen aus Berlin super
cool geil Textur ist im Prinzip so wie
wenn du eine normale Thunfischdose
öffnest bisschen rumrührst so dass das
ein bisschen kleinteiliger wird ist aber
identisch und ich glaube auch dass das
geschmacklich sehr gut sein könnte weil
so alengeschmack und sowas ist ja auch
einfach dieser mehergeschmack jetzt bin
ich sehr gespannt wie dieser vegane t
für schmeckt probieren
[Musik]
wir der erste Eindruck identisch dann
kommt wieder so ein bisschen dieser
texturunterschied und auch ein leichter
Geschmacksunterschied aber im ersten
Moment hast du da überhaupt gar keinen
Zweifel dass das hier Thunfisch ist so
von dem erstindruck das beste vegane
Ersatzprodukt was ich je gegessen habe
ich will das jetzt mal in diesem
Sandwich probieren in dem Tuna Sandwich
weil da kann ich mir vorstellen dass
einem gar nicht mehr auffällt wenn man
das so im Kontext von ein Sandwich
ist
also in diesem Sandwich kein Unterschied
wer so ein tunamel Sandwich liebt sich
vegan ernähren möchte perfekt wir
befinden uns jetzt vor dem genussgarten
in Halle 7 und ich habe gehört dass hier
ein alter Bekannter ist wir halten mal
die Augen auf und überlegt mal ob
erkennt ich sag euch gleich wer es ist
bist Du fleißig ja auf jeden Fall
natürlich Lukas everersmerer erinnert
euch ein Tag Koch von einem persönlichen
Koch es war wunderbar es war super
lecker was hier macht sieht auch lecker
aus kann man was probieren
woll was essen ja gerne doch immer ich
ma das haupberuflich ich weß Traumjob
ich check mal Platz und dann ma was zum
Teilen geil super danke schön ach ja das
sieht do direkt wieder super aus also
die Sachen die wir getestet haben waren
zwar sehr lecker aber ich glaube alles
was convenience ist kann so ein
richtigen Koch wie den Lukas nicht
ersetzen wir werden hier verwöhnt mama
mia eine unglaubliche Vielfalt die die
Welt noch nicht gesehen hat wir fangen
hier vorne an wir hab unseren catch of
the
daysabeltenunter warmes
kickererbsengemüse oben drauf eine
trüffelcreme und vegane Garnele bisschen
kesse und ponzu hollond hier habe ich
kartoffelpüe mit J und Röstzwiebeln ist
halt einfach geil in der Mitte ist ein
French Toast Croissant mit einer
Frischkäsecreme boah das klingt krass
Raviolis gefüllt mit lila Kartoffeln
Speck und ponu hollandä geil Alter also
so gut werden wir heute nicht noch mal
essen wir lassen uns diese Vielfalt hier
jetzt schmecken ich würde sagen es war
ein sehr interessanter und sehr
unterhaltsamer Tag hier auf der Anuga
schreibt mal in die Kommis ob ihr
nächstes auch wieder hier sein sollen es
gibt noch so viel zu entdecken und jedes
Jahr neue danke fürs zusehen bis dann
ciao ciao